i guess on a smaller sense
trying to get some um
schedule like a
routine in into my life
uh a healthy routine
because i've i've just been so on the go
i'm never in one place for a long like
time
to be able to
get healthy habits and
i'd like that's that's a big challenge
for me right now yeah like what do you
do for your well-being what do you do
are you a big uh advocate for exercise
and activity i mean what is it you do to
keep your mind straight um
so i journal that's like a big one every
morning a journal and for how long
however long i feel like
sometimes i write like a paragraph
sometimes i write like three pages wow
um
but and it's just like dumping things
but i think
i i think it's really important to take
some time to reflect on your life
and and think about your life because
if not it'll just go
in a direction
and you have to take aim like you have
to
curate your life uh and i think
journaling is something that really
helps me
feel like i'm
active in being a creator of of my life
and
how it's going and and who i am and i
think a lot of times we just get
swept up in in the momentum of things
and the next thing you know it's like a
year has gone by and for 10 years or 10
years and
have you done what you wanted to do or
are you
you know going in a direction you want
to go are you the person that you want
to be
and that was a big one for me learning
when i was going through that hard time
is
like the
if you you can be whoever you want to be
like just start doing the things that
that person would do
like you want to be the person who works
out every day then just work out every
day like just do it like start doing it
yeah um
yeah it takes one step at a time it
sounds so cliche but like you have to
start somewhere it sounds so
overwhelming when you're like i have to
do this i have to lose weight i have to
do yes if you think about the whole
thing
but tomorrow or right now
do it go for a walk do it's those little
things that just add up add up to get
you where you want to go
join us every week as we discuss all
that is smallville we're going to watch
every episode that's right with you
talkville the ultimate smallville
podcast we're going to go way back join
tom welling and michael rosenbaum every
week as they rewind every episode of
smallville and discuss their experiences
with friends fans and co-stars talkville
the ultimate smallville podcast
you